Let's start out with a brief look at the environment facing us in this market.
This chart indicates the sales trend we've experienced over the past three years...
...and where we expect to go over the next three years.
As you see here, the overall market size has been expanding quickly.
Analysts predict it could double again by 2012.
The key to success here is to have a series of products that meet the market needs earlier than competitors.
But which products? We need to understand our customers' requirements fully.
So, last month I organized a three-person marketing team to determine key customer requirements.
The time frame for this project is three months.
We will have our final report in September; I would be pleased to share it with you.
That's great. It should be very valuable information for us.
Is that only for the U.S. market?
No, we have been researching global markets, including Japan.
Other markets include Germany, the UK, France, and China.
Regarding the Japanese market, we would appreciate any input you could provide, Taka.
My team would be glad to help.